alors je ne vais pas vous le cacher j'ai
le coeur vide c'est assez difficile à
décrire mais je crois que je n'ai jamais
autant aimé une série et plus jamais on
revivra quelque chose comme ça alors
évidemment nous aurons des expériences
similaires il y aura d'autres séries
incroyables mais jamais on ne revivra
l'expérience d'arc
je pensais à la base vous proposer
pourquoi pas un trois théories parler
des mystères des choses non résolues on
va dire mais je pense qu'une vidéo sur
la fin de la série ce serait déjà pas
mal comme une sorte un petit peu de
dommages à dark la meilleure série
netflix
je vous encourage vivement à me partager
vos opinions et vos avis via l'espace
commentaires
c'est dans ces moments là qu internet
est vraiment une belle évolution afin de
nous réunir pour parler et échanger
autour de ce genre de chefs-d'oeuvre
nous possédons tous nos émotions nos
perceptions dû à notre expérience
personnelle et à notre vécu donc
partageons profitons ensemble de ce
moment unique car jamais on ne revivra
spoiler alert évidemment on va parler de
toute la saison 3 donc si vous n'avez
pas vu je vous conseille vivement
d'aller la voir avant de regarder cette
vidéo
donc vous êtes prévenus bon et juste
avant de commencer par rapport à la
dernière vidéo sur dark je saigne
beaucoup trouvé ma prononciation des
noms bizarres mais j'ai vu en vo
allemande
donc c'est pour ça si ma prononciation
des noms est un peu différente j'ai ce
pas comment elle est en français donc
voilà ne soyez pas surpris si des fois
je peux dire mag nous par exemple ou des
trucs comme ça quoi
allez on y va
donc fini
le petit âne hausse était bien la cause
ultime l'origine de tous les problèmes
dus à la perte de sa famille
tragiquement décédé dans un accident de
voiture
dan rose construira alors une machine
pour trouver une autre temporalité une
autre dimension où sa famille auraient
survécu mais c'est au final sa propre
réalité qu'il fragmentera en deux autres
dimensions le monde de adam et le monde
2 et va il est vrai qu'au final c'est
cohérent quand on s'y penche un petit
peu puisque d'arc a toujours fonctionné
avec le trick et rat et le chiffre 3
l'homme à trois vies quand il perd sa
naïveté quand il perd son innocence et
quand il perd la vie tout court
nous suivons toujours trois âges
différents on voyage de 33 ans en 33 ans
toutes les symboliques sont vraiment
ultra forte c'est tout de même
ouf que thanos soit la cause de tout et
qu'en plus ce soit lié à son désir un
manque la perte d'un proche qu'il
aimerait ramener à la vie
je ne sais pas vous mais depuis la
saison une j'ai toujours trouvé ce
personnage décalé par rapport à dark il
n'était reliée à personne c'était
vraiment le personnage hors boucle on ne
connaissait rien de la famille tanner
aus et il s'est retrouvé finalement avec
charlotte sans rien demander
j'ai toujours pensé que c'était un choix
de hanau et de elisabeth de lui avoir
déposé charlotte pour qu'elle soit
protégée du monde post apocalyptique
j'étais bien loin du compte et [ __ ]
adam porté finalement vraiment bien son
nom absolument toutes les relations sans
exception chaque détail a été créé et
reproduit par lui à l'infini c'est
vraiment là où dark c'est puissant rien
n'est laissé au hasard
mais vraiment rien d'où toutes les
choses horribles et inimaginable qu'il a
pu faire tout comme eva d'ailleurs alors
je pense que certains ont peut-être du
mal à comprendre la fin de la série
pourquoi tout le monde disparaît et on
se retrouve avec six personnages aux
alentours des années 2000 2005 à peu
près et bien comme il a été démontré et
thann ross a créé deux réalités qui
n'aurait jamais dû exister
khaddam a donc façonné par le biais
d'une et eva par le biais
une autre étant donné que la réalité
originel a été fragmentée en 3 nous
retrouvons donc les influences de la
réalité originel le voeu d'un monde sans
winneden comme mentionné par katharina
qui sera répétée par ulrich tout au long
de la série le ciré jaune
fowler et son oeil les personnages en
eux mêmes alors c'est peut-être
personnel comme vision mais c'est comme
si on avait que des morceaux dans les
deux dimensions qui nous sont proposés
des personnages qui ne sont pas entier
prenant que des aspects de personnalités
du monde originel qui lui est entier
comment je pourrais bien expliquer ça
par exemple dans la réalité de adam
winneden est constitué à fond de non
dits et de secret qui deviennent
extrêmement lourd pour le scénario
puisque tout le monde se cache tout
alors que dans la réalité des va c'est
tout l'un verse tout le monde ça vous
tout au bout d'un moment sans rien
cacher alors que par moments ils le
devraient l'exemple le plus flagrant là
dessus est alexander tiedemann qui
dévoilera son plus grand secret à son
fils bart hausse et qui souhaitera
montrer les fûts plainte de déchets
radioactifs à charlotte
c'est d'ailleurs un secret si lourd
qu'il n'aurait jamais dû dévoilé qu'au
final à tous les coups bas sa relation
avec berthot ça a été détruite avec ça
bref comme si dans une réalité les
personnages étaient beaucoup trop
honnête et dans l'autre beaucoup plus
timide modeste on va dire ils ne se
disent rien sauf qu'évidemment une
dualité ne mène à rien l'ombre et la
lumière
le monde n'est pas tout blanc ou tout
noir mais d'une infinité et de gris
c'est pour ça que l'origine et la
version complète je ne sais pas si vous
avez bien compris ce que je voulais vous
dire alors évidemment pourquoi on se
retrouve avec fowler en couple avec anna
bernadette sans doute en couple avec
peter ou encore regin a ou catarina et
bien car comme mentionné par claudia
alias un des meilleurs personnages de la
série d'ailleurs ils sont hors boucle
hors de tous ne crée répété par yonath
et martha et on en revient ce que je
vous dis
et le monde originel étant fragmenté ce
monde a servi de source pour les deux
réalités en reprenant des détails déjà
existant dans ce dernier comme dan rose
par exemple qui est l'origine du
problème dans le monde originel existe
un âge et en os qui est comme une sorte
de scientifiques du temps et de l'espace
comme il nous l'a été montré dans
l'épisode 7 donc nous avons un tas
grosse également dans les deux réalités
mais en soit il est fragmenté c'est une
interprétation personnelle évidemment
mais celui de la dimension de adam
semble énormément relié au temps tandis
que celui d'eva serait plus en fonction
de l'espace ce qui expliquerait pourquoi
ils ont des machines à voyager à travers
les dimensions par exemple adam et eve
apporte ces noms car ils sont
véritablement les premiers l'union du
iona ce de la réalité de adam et de la
martha de la réalité deva a donné
naissance à l'inconnu sept personnes qui
se déplacent à trois avec trois âges
différents entre les réalités le temps
il a été confondu avec l'origine car
c'est lui qui donne naissance à l'arbre
généalogique qui perturbe toute la série
et ce dans les deux dimensions l'inconnu
le noun à une relation avec haguenets ce
n'est celles et ceux dont les deux
dimensions
cette dernière avait affirmé avoir été
avec un pasteur qui avait perdu la foi
et le nom a été pasteur un court moment
de sa vie ensemble ils ont donné
naissance à 30 tennis scène qui ensuite
a eu avec rihanna oulrich qui avec
katarina a eu martha magnus et mikel qui
lui par le biais de son voyage dans le
temps à hull yonath yonath qui est donc
le père de l'inconnu qui donc se
retrouvera avec agde nes et ainsi de
suite c'est infini absolument toute la
famille nilsen n'aurait jamais dû
exister
excepté
erna qui est la seule et véritable
nilsen celle qui a adopté à gkn s il lui
a donné son nom qu'elle a perpétué à
travers les âges par le biais de sa
descendance la famille nilsen s'arrête
donc à erna dans les années 1920 et
évidemment à gneiss est en et de l'union
de bartos et dia bâ ce n'est pas une
relation qui aurait dû exister
ensuite la famille doppler et et
gangréné par l'arrivée de charlotte et
de noix alias anneau lui aussi fils de
saguenay c'est bartos charlotte a été
amenée bébé à thann rospars sahel du
futur elisabeth sous les ordres de adam
ce dernier les lèvera et plus tard avec
peter ils auront elisabeth et francesca
est une fois de plus on est sur une
boucle infinie entre charlotte et
elisabeth
aucun de ces personnages net issu d'une
relation temporel scène
c'est pourquoi ils font partie d'une e
et disparaissent peter est présent à la
fin car sa présence est saine entre
guillemets la famille doppler et
d'implémenter dont winneden depuis
toujours par le biais de berne doppler
il est le créateur de la centrale ce
dernier a eu un fils avec greta doppler
alors d'après le site de netflix
il ne serait pas le véritable père del
guy greta aurait apparemment eu une
liaison avec un personnage inconnu ça
j'avoue cela m'a échappé mais cela ne
change en rien la chose car elle gay a
hérité du nom de doppler et du coup avec
une femme hors de winneden il a eu peter
c'est également le cas pour anaky est
issu de la famille
kruger une famille non issus de liaison
temporel ou dimensionnelle pareil pour
katarina qui est une albers une famille
qui elle aussi n'est en aucun cas liée
aux problèmes temporel
tout comme torben et son frère ou plutôt
sa soeur bernadette ici de la famille
fowler ils sont tous issus d'une famille
dite normale en soi alors évidemment je
n'ai pas parlé de regin a car je ne
m'attendais pas à ce que ça soit autant
une clé scénaristique
claudia a finalement eu une liaison avec
berne doppler l'ex directeur de la
centrale dont elle a pris la relève il
l'a caché à tous une relation assumer
dans le monde originel
la famille kidman et en or problème
temporel puisque egon avec doris ont eu
claudia qui avec berne a eu regin a de
manière classique et d'ailleurs c'est là
où il pourrait y avoir un petit peu de
spéculation car alexander n'étant pas
relié aux problèmes temporel à la base
il devrait également exister dans le
monde originel avec certainement là même
une usurpation d'identité
vu que son vrai nom et boris ni valdes
mais tout est donc modulable car étant
donné qu oulrich n'existe pas il n'y a
jamais eu un quiproquo sur la première
fois de katharina et oulrich dévoilé
soi-disant par regin a à la police alors
que c'était en fait
anna ce qui fait que ces dernières sont
donc devenus amis et que regin a n'étant
pas isolé n'a jamais rencontré alexander
vous voyez ce que je veux dire c'est ce
genre de détails qui étouffe dans la
série donc évidemment bartos n'est
jamais n'est pour le moment et n'aurait
jamais dû naître aussi est ce lié avec
dia pour avoir noah et agnèse bref
et vu que claudia n'a pas dû disparaître
à cause des voyages dans le temps et
qu'elle assume pleinement sa relation
avec berne comme on le voit avec la
photo à la fin
c'est elle qui devrait être toujours à
la tête de la centrale centrale qui
normalement a vu le jour sans souci
puisque aucun cadavre n'a été retrouvé
sur le chantier et donc aucun frein par
rapport au maire quant à la signature du
permis de construire ainsi qu'une
mauvaise communication autour du projet
et vu qu'il n'ya pas de mort caché sur
le chantier et inexpliqués les détails
du scénario sont très forts rien n'est
laissé au hasard c'est juste génial
bon je pense arriver à la fin de mes
pensées et je peux vous dire que ça fait
du bien de se libérer et d'en parler
alors évidemment on pourrait détailler
des heures mais je ne suis pas sûr que
ce soit très pertinent et ce n'était au
final plus le but de la série avec cette
saison 3 je pense je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de penser à anna enceinte
d'ulrich dans la dimension de eva cela
aurait amené de nouveaux personnages une
nouvelle descendance encore inconnue
peut-être à l'histoire mais maintenant
que nous avons les réponses
ce n'est pas vraiment pertinent de
savoir ce que cela donnerait en soi
puisque la finalité sera et restera
toujours la même
ou bien même l'union d'ehlg et qui a
donné naissance à peter ce sont des
détails qui n'apporteront rien au
scénario tout comme greta par rapport à
berne
comme je le disais
je vous en supplie mais profitez bien de
ce moment pour partager vos ressentis et
vos émotions car jamais mais jamais on
ne revivra une telle chose
la hype et là la passion est présente
c'est vraiment le moment après je dis ça
mais peut-être qu on revivra quelque
chose de similaire dans 33 ans qui sait
dark restera pour moi à jamais une série
incroyable un véritable chef-d'oeuvre
d'une qualité rare c'est tout à fait le
genre de séries que je montrerai ma
descendance
en espérant que évidemment mon fils ne
soit pas mon père je vous remercie
sincèrement d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
je vous souhaite le meilleur bien
évidemment le vide va être très dur à
combler mais ça m'a fait vraiment du
bien et du vraiment plaisir de parler
avec vous et de pouvoir me libérer que
le lay en art soit avec vous bien
évidemment cet argot rock
allez au revoir tout le monde
[Musique]